[Musique]
dans la nuit alors qu'on entend les
cloches de la cathédrale du Christ
Sauveur avec tous ces apparents la
traditionnelle célébration de nuit pour
la Pâques orthodoxe se déroule comme à
la coutume
le président Vladimir Poutine ni même
présent un contraste avec ce qui se
passe en Ukraine
pour une deuxième année la plus
importante célébration du calendrier
orthodoxe et bouleversée les Ukrainiens
s'ajuste malgré les ruines les
couvre-feu et les dangers de
bombardements
car les églises ne sont pas épargnées
comme celle-ci près de zapporuja
détruites par un missile S300 les
fidèles tentent maintenant de sauver les
reliques qui restent intactes au milieu
des ruines
du ministère de la Défense russe
rapporte d'ailleurs des avancées pour
ces troupes dans la ville de backmouth
à l'occasion de la part orthodoxe un
nouvel échange de prisonniers a eu lieu
le 14e depuis le début du conflit
dans une vidéo publiée par le groupe
Wagner le chef de la milice par
hamilitarus parle d'une centaine de
prisonniers rendus la présidente
ukrainienne avance plutôt le chiffre de
130 Ukrainiens libérés sans préciser
combien de Russes étaient inclus dans ce
transfert
le président selinski a livré un message
d'espoir à son peuple rappelant que la
foi unit les ukrainiens et que
l'objectif de tous reste la victoire
pour ceux qui restent sur le front les
plus chanceux recevront le traditionnel
penpark et auront droit à un repas
partagé entre frères d'armes ici Carla
Oliveira Radio-Canada Montréal